effectivement ça fait trois quatre ans
maintenant que avec ma famille les
enfants on a décidé de quitter une vie
qu'on avait plus ou moins classiques en
suisse pour aller s'installer dans le
sud de la france sur un terrain agricole
où on a posé un habitat plutôt léger et
autour duquel on essaie de mettre en
place une vie qu'on lire qui répondent
un petit peu plus aux valeurs qui sont
importantes pour nous et aux valeurs
qu'on aimerait aussi transmettre à nos
enfants
alors voilà quand on m'a contacté pour
parler un petit peu ici ce soir de cette
expérience
on m'a suggéré on m'a suggéré de dire
que j'étais fribourgeois d'abord marqué
des points
et puis on va surtout suggéré de parler
du pourquoi de ce changement
alors moi le pourquoi ça me paraissait
complètement évident donc j'ai dit bien
sûr volontiers et je suis devant mon
ordinateur je me suis dit dans une demi
heure c'est plié
et puis il se trouve que deux heures et
demie après j'étais toujours devant mon
ordinateur on sait en essayant de
trouver le pourquoi les mots en fait de
ce pour quoi
et du coup je me suis peut-être c'est
peut-être pas la meilleure des façons de
transmettre et puis je me suis dirigé
vers quelque chose qui est plus de
l'ordre du ressenti et donc j'aimerais
du coup avec vous ce soir faire un petit
exercice un type d'exercice tout simple
de leur connexion à soi-même pour
essayer de ressentir un petit peu mieux
ce pourquoi donc tout le monde peut le
faire il n'y a pas besoin de capacités
particulières ni quoi que ce soit je
vous demanderais juste pour ça de fermer
les yeux ça a duré quelques minutes et
puis vous pouvez comme moi prendre une
bonne respiration et une fois que c'est
fait vous pouvez vous concentrer sur un
point au centre de votre cage thoracique
ou au centre de votre estomac
là où vous ressentez un petit peu les
émotions et puis mais j'aurais aimé que
vous essayez de ressentir qu'est-ce-qui
qu'est ce qui se passe justement dans ce
point là juste maintenant quel type
d'énergie quels types d'émotions travers
cette zone positif ou négatif
une fois que vous arrivez à ressentir ça
plus ou moins j'aurais aimé qu'on fait
vous essayez de vous rappeler un moment
de bonheur intense que vous avez vécu
dans votre bille essayer de ressentir
aussi qu'est ce qui se passe du coup à
l'intérieur de ce monstre ou dans cette
zone dans laquelle bourg santé des
émotions
un moment de bonheur intense qui peut
être la naissance d'un enfant qui peut
être les retrouvailles avec une personne
mais plus vu depuis très longtemps
essayé de ressentir ça peut être aussi
un tout tout tout premier baiser avec
votre amoureuse
voilà en gardant toujours les yeux
fermés j'aurais aimé maintenant qu'on
fasse un petit travail de mémoire
et puis on essaie doivent traverser la
journée qui vient de s'écouler
toujours en essayant d'identifier un
petit peu les énergies les émotions qui
nous ont accompagnés tout au long de
cette journée a commencé par le moment
où votre réveil a sonné ce matin le
moment où vous avez quitté votre lit
essayer de ressentir quels étaient les
énergies qui vous appelez vers cette
journée et puis ensuite j'aimerais
parler trop vite mais imaginez vous dans
votre rituel du matin
le choix des habits le petit déjeuner
que vous avez peut-être partager avec
quelqu'un
et puis gentiment vous quittez votre
domicile et votre véhicule ou un
transport en commun et puis vous partez
votre mère votre lieu de travail sont
hélas encore le type d'énergie qui vous
accompagne en ce moment vous arrivez sur
votre lieu de travail
vous rencontrez vos collègues la matinée
c'est cool gentiment jusque vers la
pause du midi
là aussi vous pourrez essayer de vous
rappeler ce repas que vous avez
peut-être partager avec des personnes
j'appuie gentiment retour sur le lieu de
travail l'après midi qui s'écoule aussi
vous avez peut-être rencontré un
challenge ou pas et puis tout gentiment
cette journée qui touche à sa fin et
puis c'est le moment d'être quitté son
lieu de travail de reprendre ce véhicule
que vous avez pris ce matin de retourner
éventuellement chez vous mais peut-être
plus facilement directement ici voilà
avant de d'ouvrir les yeux j'aurais aimé
encore que vous essayez de vous imaginer
sur votre lit de mort dans 10 20 h 40
ans plaide demain et puis que vous
portiez vous quand vous êtes
paisiblement installés pas de stress
vous portez un regard sur cette vie qui
vient de s'écouler
puis on vous dit quelque chose du style
ben voilà j'avais à disposition un
millier peut-être un million de vies à
choix et puis ben moi c'est celle là que
j'ai choisi voilà c'est là qu'ils aient
du sens pour moi puis une dernière fois
vous essayez de voir comment ça résonne
en vous ceci voilà je vous propose
d'ouvrir maintenant les yeux et avant
que je vous parle encore un tout petit
peu de moi j'aurais eu une petite
question à vous poser est ce qu a parmi
vous dans la salle les gens qui se
sentent pas complètement à leur place on
parle pas de ce soir 1 ce soir c'est
clair qu'on est tous très content d'être
ici
j'ai entendu qu'il y ait une soupe de
chalet après l'armée de manière plus
globale dans la vie est ce que est ce
qu'il ya parmi vous les gens qui se
sentent pas exactement là où il devrait
être là où il est
merci je vois qu'à une ou deux mains qui
se lèvent timidement
beaucoup de gens sont venus avec leur
patron ils n'osent pas lever la main
je vous rassure en fait moi ya trois
quatre ans c'était complètement clair
pour moi que j'étais pas du tout à la
place où il devait être et pourtant ce
soir j'aurais fais partie des gens qui
ont pas levé la main sur parce que
fondamentalement je suis malhonnête mais
aussi parce que pour plusieurs raisons
la première c'est que faire le constat
après 30 40 ou 50 ans de vie qui on
n'est pas là où on aimerait être ou pas
là où on devrait être pas et vidéo ce
qui est massacrée constat d'échec
puis se trouve qu'on a créé une société
où l'échec pas spécialement une valeur
refuge
l'autre raison c'est que c'est parfois
très compliqué de se rendre compte qu'on
n'est pas à notre place
parce que de nouveaux on a créé une
société qui nous projette énormément aux
modèles par tous les médias auxquels on
est confrontés
et si les modèles auxquels on a tendance
à s'identifier et consciemment ou
inconsciemment et sur ses modèles des
fois on peut lire des choses du style la
liberté quelqu'un est un concept assez
costaud quand la liberté c'est un
abonnement de téléphone illimité ou le
vrai luxe c'est l'espace qui a dans
l'habitacle de ma voiture
et puis bon finalement fini par y croire
à ce genre de truc là
on finit par y croire et du coup au
moment du bilan qu'en temps en temps on
se pose pour faire un bilan
eh bien on fait la comparaison dit ok la
voiture c'est bon gelé l'abonnement
illimité c'est ok j'ai pas encore george
clooney mais la machine à café qui va
avec et c'est donc tout semble
finalement bien se passer quoi
heureusement on a tous je pense vraiment
tous une petite voix à l'intérieur de
nous qui des fois seul un petit peu la
larme
alors si chez certains elle est vraiment
très profondément enfouis chez d'autres
il a un petit peu plus en surface
et puis cette petite voix et nous
challenge nous posons des questions du
type
est-ce que c'est complètement dans
l'ordre des choses que je vois mes
enfants deux fois une demi-heure par
jour que je parte mes parents dans une
maison il ya des vieux nous posent des
questions du type est ce que c'est
complètement logique que je passe autant
d'heures par jour voir autant d'heures
ou de jours par mois à travailler pour
pouvoir payer une voiture que j'ai dû
acheter pour aller travailler
elle est forte ce petit voyage ou des
choses encore du style est ce que c'est
normal de lutter d'être en lutte pendant
47 48 semaines par année parce que
vraiment les gens son lutin temps dès
lors et de seconde allait dans les métro
etc
c'est dur le quotidien ce qui est normal
comme ça d'être en lutte pendant 47 48
semaines par année pour les quatre ou
cinq dernières de l'année m'enfuir le
plus loin possible de mon lieu de vie
pour aller vivre une vie qu'elle a pu
diamétralement opposée de celle que je
vis au quotidien en est on bien sûr la
sensation que ça dans des chiens c'est
la vraie vie quoi quand même alors là
quand on a cette petite vie au ouaki
nous qui nous chalenge on peut se sentir
des fois un petit peu comme ça quoi et à
moins qu'on soit fan 10 sport extrême
c'est pas toujours forcément extrêmement
agréable de sentir un peu ce ce vide
sous nos pieds est très souvent du coup
on a tendance à vouloir museler cette
voie par tout un tas de stratagèmes qui
souvent se passe là dedans et de
l'enfouir de nouveau le plus
profondément possible prêt nous dérange
plus jusqu'à la prochaine fois
un matin avant de partir au travail
ma fille éliane fille alia
cela m'a attrapé par la cravate moi
aussi le portait une cravate à moi pas
attraper comme ça on va regarder dans le
blanc des yeux qu'elle m'a dit papa
pourquoi t'es pas plus ou moins avec
nous qu'est-ce que j'ai répondu
la sig reçu
exactement on a répondu à peu près la
même chose je vis un truc du style ben
tu vois ma fille ravie on choisit pas
toujours
c'est comme ça il faut je dois etc
je lui ai fait un bec sur le front je
suis parti travailler cette question
qu'elle m'a posé là et m'a occupé
vraiment toute la journée et plus que la
question
elle m'a posé sa réponse que je lui ai
donné nous occuper toute la journée
belle réponse de losers alors que moi au
quotidien je tenais un discours vraiment
plutôt de winner j'avais des équipes de
vente se marrent responsabilités et
c'est donc je leur disais des choses du
style quand on veut on peut il suffit de
se fixer des objectifs ont choisi là où
on veut aller
impossible n'est pas fribourg joie etc
mais ma fille à la maison je lui disais
c'est un peu différent à la maison tu
vois comment c'est moi c'est un peu plus
compliqué non en fait qu'est-ce que
j'aurais dû lui dire si j'avais voulu
être fondamentalement honnête j'ai dit
que j'étais malade et si j'avais voulu
être fondamentalement honnête j'aurais
dû dire quelque chose du style tu
l'auras amelia j'ai choisi le choisi
d'organiser ma vie d'une certaine
manière
ou finalement tu fais pas partie des
priorités soit qui est beaucoup plus
compliqué pour moi à dire ça bien sûr ça
aurait été beaucoup plus honnête
quelques jours plus tard on s'était
peut-être même dans la même journée je
ne me rappelle plus mais
j'ai croisé cette phrase là c'était pas
sous cette forme là c'était un graffiti
je crois à lausanne et c'est une phrase
qui a eu un impact sur moi extrêmement
fort même s'il est extrêmement simple et
que la plupart d'entre vous la
connaissez peut-être moi c'est la
première fois que l'alizé et puis ça
fait vraiment très très fort impact
parce que jusque là moi j'étais un grand
râleur j'ai toujours mais j'ai râlé sur
plein de choses je râlais sur le
changement climatique je râlais sur les
multinationales jallet sur la pharma la
mal bouffe etc
et puis j'ai râlé comme s'il y avait
quelqu'un juste à côté de moi qui
prenais des notes puis qu'il disait ok
on s'en charge
on y va
mais y'a pas ça et du coup cette phrase
elle m'a simplement remis devant mes
responsabilités et puis aussi et surtout
elle m'a rappelé à quel point j'avais un
pouvoir en mai main aussi de changer ne
serait-ce que mon propre nom en a moins
et si changement proprement on a moins
directement sa une influence sur le
monde de ceux qui m'entourent et du coup
aussi sur le monde de ce qui entoure ce
qui m'entoure etc etc
alors voilà tout ce que je vous raconte
la serène bien compliqué quelques mois
plus tard j'ai donné ma démission
et voilà comme je dis c'est l'origine
d'une ce changement chez nous ils
pourquoi c'est des choses toutes simples
une petite prise de conscience une
discussion entre quatre yeux être ma
fille cravate tendu et puis un graffiti
qu'une démission
donc c'est des choses vraiment simple et
je pense qu'elle habille
fondamentalement et simple n'est pas
compliqué et nous on à être humain une
tendance vraiment incroyable arriver à
cela compliqué et comment ça complique
énormément on a l'impression aussi que
le changement est très compliqué quand
on va défaire tout cette usine à gaz
qu'on a mis en place et du coup on
change finalement très peu de choses
dans notre vie à part des toute chose
qui nous permette de nous rappeler qu'on
est vivant et puis de tenir jusqu'au
lendemain paire de chaussures changer un
téléphone etc
mais le cadre de notre vie on a
l'impression qu'il est immuable c'est un
peu comme cette scène en fait ce soit
les super mais lui et moi je n'ai pas
choisi i la taille et la couleur la
forme la matière ni rien alors bien sûr
les gens qui ont choisi cette scène ils
n'ont pas fait de manière mal
intentionnés pourtant ils l'ont fait
simplement en fonction de leurs propres
besoins leurs propres contraintes c'est
pas les miennes mais je peux m'adapter à
700 ch peu
me conformer toute une vie durant rester
ici par contre si j'ai l'intimé
conviction que ma vie ça se passe là où
vous êtes vous pas ce que je vois qui
est la couleur si tu vois il ya des
sourires et ben ça vaut la peine de se
poser la question est ce que finalement
la frontière entre yahoo je suis et puis
là où je devrais être
qu'est ce que c'est quand on se
rencontre la frontière ici finalement
elle est super fine la frontière
psychologique et les normes la barrière
psychologique mais la barrière physique
elle est très très fine du couvent si
vraiment je pense que ma vie elles se
passent plutôt de ce côté
alors ça vaut la peine parfois le faire
juste un pas de côté